zurück bei Bild live mit einem
Schriftsteller Aufstand gegen das
Gendern einer der größten der deutschen
Sprache einer der größten deutschen
Schriftsteller aktuell Uwe Telkamp der
wettert gegen die wie er sagt
Vergewaltigung von Sprache am Abend hat
helkampf in Neubrandenburg seit neuen
Roman vorgestellt und dabei ist ihm
tatsächlich der Hut hochgegangen wegen
der gendersprache die Sprache sei wie
eine tausendstimmige Orgel sagte er und
gender Sprache sei das wenn man einem
Organisten einfach zwei Register der
Orgel wegnehmen würde weil diese
irgendwie kolonial belastet sein Holler
da hat aber auf dem Tisch gehabt
seine Schriftsteller Kollegen viel
lauter zu sein gegen diese gender
Sprache ein Schriftsteller Aufstand also
gegen das Gendern und Helga macht
ohnehin längst so vieles wütend was hier
in diesem Land passiert zuletzt hat er
am Tag der Deutschen Einheit am 3
oktober gegen die Grünen und vor allem
gegen Robert Habeck gewettert
sind durch unser Land geht und die
Entwicklung verfolgt der kann meiner
Meinung nach nicht ohne einen gewissen
Zorn inzwischen auskommen wir reden im
Jahr 2022 überhaupt arbeiten geschildert
habe wir müssen vorbereiten ich muss für
meine Familie überlegen was ich immer
Wohnung ohne Ofen für eine
brennmöglichkeit Kriege im Jahr 2020
aber die Welt wollen
die Welt vorbereiten und kriegen es
nicht mal fertig unsere Bahn pünktlich
fährt dass die Leute sich mit was
ordentlichen mit ihrem Beruf mit ihrem
Alltag auseinandersetzen können da
fragen Sie woher mein Song kommt da
frage ich wo die Ruhe noch
heruntergesellschaft
parlamentsredaktion hier bei uns im
Studio schönen guten Morgen Ralf so da
ist sie mal richtig der Hut hochgegangen
was sagst du dazu das war ja sehr
erfrischend also für einen für einen
Schriftsteller wir haben gerade
Buchmesse in Frankfurt sehr erfrischend
sehr geradlinig und geradeaus Tellkamp
hat ja viele Probleme es gibt ja etliche
die in seinen Romanen
da
migrationskritische Untertöne sehen und
ihn deshalb boykottieren und so weiter
und dass er einfach so gerade raus
spricht das ist sehr sympathisch wettert
ordentlich gegen die gendersprache am
Abend in Neubrandenburg das macht jetzt
Schlagzeilen und erfordert tatsächlich
ja von seinen Schriftsteller Kollegen
also die die jeden Tag ganz besonders
besonders kunstvoll mit der Sprache
umgehen wehrt euch dagegen werden sich
viele anschließen was meinst du
Künstler sind in der Regel ein eher
zartes und vorsichtiges Volk aber gerade
was die Sprache betrifft ist das
natürlich ein Problem du musst dich ja
bekennen wenn du irgendetwas schreibst
im Roman Doppelpunkt oder Unterstriche
drin und sprachhäubler bis jetzt haben
sich Schriftsteller der weitestgehend
abseits gehalten aber
irgendwann muss man sich dann schon
entscheiden nur laut sind sie bis jetzt
noch nicht geworden das letzte Mal gab
es einen Aufstand der Schriftsteller zur
Rechtschreibreform das liegt ein paar
Jahre zurück ich könnte mir gut
vorstellen dass das auch so ein Thema
ist was man jetzt irgendwie offensiv
beschreiben muss ein Gedicht ist
eigentlich ingenieursprache schwer
denkbar überhaupt hast du persönlich das
Gefühl dass man der Gender Sprache geht
inzwischen bisschen zu weit na es ist
einfach penetrant und also ich habe auch
den Eindruck dass es unnötig ist es ist
ja im Prinzip die die der Zwang in der
Wortwahl die eigene Weltsicht zu
dokumentieren also wenn ich gendere dann
will ich ja nicht nur das weibliche
Geschlecht mit meinen sondern ich möchte
zu erkennen geben dass ich die gesamte
Vielfalt der Geschlechter wie sie einige
gender Aktivisten sehen dass ich die
auch so sehe und dass ich sie mittrage
und mich dafür einsetze und ich kann
eigentlich als normaler Bürger verlangen
dass mir nicht jemand seine ideologische
Weltsicht um die Ohren haut sondern
einfach mit mir normal spricht und wenn
man ehrlich sind auf welcher wird denn
von
Liebe gäste:innen gesprochen also kam
einfach also ich bin nicht es geht also
um den Gebrauch unserer Worte und es
geht in diesen Tag um ein ganz
besonderes Wort in der Politik nämlich
das Machtwort vom Kanzler von Olaf
Scholz der hat immer auf dem Tisch
gehauen hat und seine lieblingsminister
sozusagen zur Saison gerufen hat vor
allen Dingen Robert Habeck diese
Geschichte vom Machtwort stimmt denn
überhaupt so Kompetenz ich wollte gerade
sagen das korrekte Wort ist
Richtlinienkompetenz Paragraf 1 der
Geschäftsordnung dieser Bundesregierung
aber Machtwort klingt natürlich schöner
und es klingt nach durchregieren das
klingt nach Kraft war das so hat er auf
den Tisch gehauen die beiden Sitzen im
gegenüber und dann müssen sich halt
Lindner und Harbeck dem Scholz beugen
weil er so heftig auf dem Tisch gehauen
hat es ist wie immer wenn Kraft
demonstriert wird ist meistens Schwäche
im Spiel und in diesem Falle war es ganz
genauso man konnte sich nicht einigen
und man hat sich dann schon am Sonntag
übrigens auf diese
fassadenschauspielerei
nicht es gab danach gar kein Treffen
weiter man hat sich am Sonntag
zusammengesetzt 12 30 bis 15 Uhr Bild
hat damals berichtet und hat sich darauf
verständigt dass man sagt was oft du
zwingst uns jetzt und dann kann ich
Robert Habeck zu meiner Basis gehen und
kann sagen ja der Scholz der war jetzt
müssen wir die 30 sie haben so getan als
hätte der Kanzler ein Machtwort
gesprochen und Robert Habeck hat zu Olaf
Scholz sinngemäß gesagt spricht doch mal
an Machtwort dann beuge ich mich dem es
gab einfach schlichtweg keine Einigung
die FDP wollte gerne eine längere
Laufzeit aller drei aacke weh mit
Bestellung von Brennstäben bis 2024 das
was für die Grünen und für die SPD
übrigens völlig indiskutabel die rote
Linie ist es werden keine Brennstäbe neu
bestellt es muss beim Ausstieg bleiben
und weil das nicht zu versöhnen war hat
man sich darauf geeinigt dann sagt du
doch das Machtwort habeg kommt gut über
seinen Parteitag der war lag da ja
zurück dort wurde beschlossen dass nur
zwei AKWs länger laufen und nach dem
Machtwort konnte dann habe ich sagen ja
Mensch der Scholz aber was soll ich
machen was heißt das jetzt konkret über
den Zustand der Ampel müssen wir jetzt
auch eine Diskussion eine dieser
Diskussionen zum Zustand und wir unserer
Bundesregierung also wenn die Grünen
Basis das einigermaßen mit Murren aber
doch friedlich schluckt dann ist diese
Krise zumindest ausgestanden vielmehr
hat ein Kanzler nicht im Arsenal das
muss man auch ganz klar sagen nach nicht
mal einem Jahr schon solche Plotten
bemühen zu müssen das ist ein heikles
Signal und das einzige was jetzt noch
zur Verfügung steht wäre die
Vertrauensfrage dann merkt man aber
wirklich dass die Koalition kurz vor dem
Ende ist sagt Ralf Schuler dankeschön
für deine aktuelle Einschätzung danke
dir
[Musik]